Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We got a bunch of questions that you guys shared,
and we'll get through those, those best I can,
and then we'll open it up for questions.
And remember, ask your question,
and most everybody did.
So everybody's getting on the membership site, I hope.
Ask your question on the box on the membership site
that makes it nice and slick, and if it's right to me,
I can see those.
Always when you have a question,
instead of waiting until Wednesday,
go to our regular website and do a search.
Now, I know we don't have a search feature
on the membership site yet.
We're working on that.
It's through a different company,
so we have to have them create a search feature.
So we are going to work on a search feature
on the membership site that doesn't exist at this point.
But go to our regular website, the contest.com,
use that little looking glass thing,
magnifying glass and search for it.
I'll say a couple of questions that were posted
are available in that, and I will point that out.
Hopefully everybody has got on the membership site.
If you have not gotten on the membership site,
what you need to do is search info at Cutters Clinic
or search membership on your made email.
So you're made email that you've used to initially contact us,
and then you may send in contacts to us in a communication with us.
That is the email that we register.
You can only have one email in the membership site.
That will be your user name.
And then you create your password.
So I'm going to that email for those who have multiple emails.
And search info at Cutters Clinic.com.
You'll find where you were invited to our membership site.
If you can't find that, just email me
at info at Cutters Clinic.com and say,
I can't find my invite.
And then I will click the box on the back office
and you will get another invite.
And then if it does end up getting pushed to like spam
or something, make sure you look at your spam.
So then you get in, you log in, you save your password,
and that's if you're forgetting it,
you could always have to just like any other site
to refresh your password.
But this has a bunch of information and answers
a lot of questions that only patients can see.
All our Zoom calls recordings are on there for the last six
years.
So make sure you go back and look at the user membership site.
OK, so here's a perfect question.
Share your thoughts on proton therapy.
Is it easier on your body than radiation?
I did a whole blog post on this.
And it should be on our regular website.
Proton therapy is a different type of radiation
that was touted.
When it came out a number of years ago,
it was a while ago, maybe 10, 12 years ago,
as a safer radiation than regular proton radiation.
Well, a regular radiation.
But in reality, I don't know that it's really proven
to be a whole lot safer.
I would still say if I had to get radiation,
I would find a clinic that had proton radiation therapy.
Versus regular radiation.
I just don't know that any studies have actually proven
that setting safer, but it is still radiation.
So radiation has its damaging effect.
So is it easier on your body than radiation?
Well, it still is radiation, so it
has just as much damaging effects.
What percentage of your cancer patients have the HLA-DQ
or that HLA-DRG?
I don't know.
In fact, we thought about actually hiring an intern
to literally scour our genes and our patients,
and be able to see.
Can everybody see my shared screen if you can?
See it, please say, yes, if you can see the Q&A at the top.
And the question that I'm going over right now,
please say that because somebody just did post
that they can't see the question.
No, can't.
OK, so we'll stop this share, and I'll do a new share.
Let's see right there.
OK, so now you can see it.
Yes.
Perfect.
Thank you.
So back to this.
This is where you look at your four
of those questions.
This is the membership site that you should be looking for.
And this is the email if you are not in the membership site
already, or you're a full member of our clinic.
You need to be at your left.
There's a lot of valuable information over there.
We're not a full member of the clinic.
Should you mail some call?
So everybody here is, so make sure you get in the membership site.
These are different genes that cause inflammation in the body.
Some have to do.
Some of these different variants have
to do with gleaned sensitivity.
Some of them have to do with bold sensitivity
and other things as well.
But they all cause hyper inflammation.
But we have never done a study.
We just don't have the manpower to do a study to have somebody
dig into everybody's genes and what type of cancers.
We always thought about doing that, but we have not.
What are the light colored seed pieces floating
in the toilet after voiding a coffee animal?
They look like pieces of chewed seeds.
It only happens with coffee.
And it is not regular voiding.
I don't know that I can answer that to anybody's satisfaction.
Certainly when you're using a coffee animal,
you are basically when you're voiding,
you have much more liquid stool.
Some of these things may be encased in a false bowel movement.
And you wouldn't see them in the stool.
That might be it.
I don't have any other possible solution or answer to that.
Certainly just could be partially digested seeds
or food or things like that, too.
The other day I had what seemed to be
more like a bowel movement prepared to seem like a more thorough
bowel movement compared to, since before, starting chemotherapy.
I noticed a small white, stringy, pitworm-looking thing
curved in this stool.
OK, I'm giggly because I love these things.
So I love it when people see parasites come out.
That's fantastic because you want to get these things out.
Now I don't know if it was a parasite or something else
that you ate.
I found a handful more and I'm unsure if they're actual parasites
or if they're fibers or recently eating Jersey sweet cures.
Today after a coffee animal found more of these fiber-looking things.
I don't know unless you fish them out of the toilet
and you put them under a microscope
you would really be able to know.
Certainly if it's a tapeworm or a roundworm,
those are big enough to know what it is.
Pinworms are much smaller.
You can see those in the stool though,
but they're smaller and they're like more grains of rice-type things.
So in order to know you'd have to do it in a study.
When you do a stool sample and they're looking for parasites,
they're really looking for the eggs, not so much the parasite itself.
MIT detoxing parasites, well, certainly could be.
That would be an exciting thing.
Or are these things just common junk detoxing from effective daily animals?
I don't know.
The truth is that most of us have a lot of cake to junk
on the sides of our intestinal walls.
So I remember reading one place,
and I don't think Miltis is true that they said that John Wade.
I don't know why they did it.
This study on John Wade's fecal matter after he passed away.
But they said he had like so many pounds of fecal matter
cake to the inside of his gut.
I think this was actually in Robin's book about that he wrote about,
that was all anti-dairy, and trying
to eat more of a plant-based diet.
And it was, they were talking about it
made mainly due to animal meat products being
cake to the sides of your intestines.
Now, I don't know how much of that is true or not.
I have no idea.
But there is certainly a digested food and junk
in your gut that eats, you know, that's your old detoxing
when you're doing this stuff.
OK, the eye-on-row-wave foot bath appears
to allow for toxins from the body to be removed.
So yes, there's that.
That's some of that is taking place.
My bath water was filthy afterward.
I thought it was amazing that it works this way.
It's so much is taken out.
OK, let's stop right there.
So just because the water is filthy,
doesn't mean that all came from you.
So there is an ionization that goes on with the eye-on-row-wave.
So you are ionizing some of the minerals in the water.
If you just took the eye-on-row-wave and you threw it
in the bucket of water and you turn it on,
you would notice some discoloration of the water.
Now typically, it's not going to get awful,
marked black, like if you had your feet in there.
So you are pulling stuff out of your body,
but don't equate to everything that's coming out of your body.
Everything that's in the water is having come out of your body.
And certainly don't equate.
I've said this 100 times that the color, oh, it's green.
So it's coming from my mild doctor, oh, it's this color.
So it's coming from my liver.
There's no real proof that any of that
is true just because of the color.
So I understand that too.
Can too much be taken out of our body?
No, not with the ion-row-wave.
With the different ionizing machines out there,
if you did them a couple of times a day,
yeah, you might pull out too many minerals,
but not with the ion-row-wave.
You're mainly using it for the frequencies
that you're getting in the body.
The ion-row-wave seems to allow for higher frequencies.
Yes, that's exactly right.
So you can use different frequencies with the ion-row-wave.
I remember reading that some researchers,
maybe Royal Life,
included identified that frequencies
in the 100 to 300 kilohertz are responsible for killing cancer.
So Rive did talk about higher frequencies several times,
but that's not all the frequencies that he used.
In order to get super high frequencies with a bulb,
you need to use a radio frequency bulb.
And even at that, it can be dangerous.
So the true right is what's called a high frequency
machine, not a radio frequency machine.
So there is a difference with that.
And if you want more detail of that,
you can look up some information
and take some courses through true right.
There can be benefits to using a radio frequency machine.
A GV4000 is a radio frequency machine.
There's also negatives to using a radio frequency machine.
Some of the negatives with the GV4000, though,
we have several at the clinic.
I have one at home when I don't really use it all anymore.
The negative is that it's bulky.
It's difficult to use the bulb that
uses radio bulbs like transmitter bulbs.
So it's a large machine.
It's not, you can't go places with that.
You couldn't take it on a trip with you
or something like that like you can with the true right.
You can't move it around the house.
Let's put it in a cart and you're only in a one-story house.
It's fragile.
It could break easy.
And it's not meant to be used overnight.
So you're using it typically just for shorter programs.
We have several patients that have a GV4000 also
that they might do during the day, just
to get some of the higher frequencies because they don't
like to use the bandwidth, such that that's a possibility
to do that too.
How important is it to have a ground-eat sheet
under the fitted sheet?
OK.
Several videos on this as well, but I'll just share this.
I don't want to do a person that asks this question.
So, depending on who you ask, if you ask Mike it true,
I think he's going to push ground-eat sheet on everybody.
Again, a ground-eat sheet of frequencies
are going to be attracted to that ground.
So if you have a ground-eat sheet on your bed
and you're laying on your back and you have the bulb on your tummy
and it stays on your tummy all night, I mean.
And you're sleeping on your back all night and you don't move.
Well, then the frequencies are going to go through you
and be attracted to the sheet.
But you're going to lose some of the frequencies
that would disperse up to your head and disperse
down to your lower extremities because the frequencies
are going to be attracted to the sheet
because they will be attracted to the ground.
So the sheet has got metal fibers in it
that it's attached to a wire that attaches to the ground
that then goes to literally the ground outside
if you're out that has ground it.
That's the idea of a ground-eat sheet.
It's getting rid of positive charges
on your body that you pick up during the day.
Very beneficial to have a ground-eat sheet
if you have EMF issues and that is a major issue for you.
But if you're using the true life, I always recommend
that you're using the ground-eat sheet
that you only have it on the lower half of your body.
So the ground-eat sheet on the bed
is only on the lower half of the bed under the fitted sheet.
So if you're using a ground-eat sheet,
I recommend that you use it only on the lower half
of your bed underneath the fitted sheet to your feet
and then you attach it to the ground
because you could be losing some of the frequencies
to the ground-eat sheet.
So that's my opinion.
You know, it's different than Mike's opinion,
but I'm not here just to sell ground-eat sheets.
You have that in the store if you want them,
it could be very beneficial, especially for people
who have EMF sensitive,
but you have to just understand that frequencies
are coming out of that bulb.
You want them to traverse your body.
If you roll over the bulb falls on your sheet
and you have a full ground-eat sheet,
then you're going to lose most of your frequencies
to the ground if you're not getting the benefit of them.
That's just nice.
Okay, talking about this person's son,
if she should avoid bone broth,
should he avoid gelatin?
I put everything in powdered in gelatin caps,
especially greens and sunspectrum.
I can't get the greens in him at all.
Sometimes I can get the sunspectrum and a smoothie,
but usually not.
When you're dealing with a child,
sometimes it's very difficult to get them
to take any type of supplements,
and I get that.
I understand that.
You just do the best you can.
I don't know how much glutamate is in a gelatin cap.
We thought to do your research on that.
That's sure different gelatin caps contain
a different amount of glutamate.
So it is the glutamide that we're talking about,
and glutamide, especially if you have a certain defect
in your genes will convert to glutamates very quickly.
So bone broth has a lot of glutamide,
el glutamide, a lot of nutritional drinks
that to heal your gut contain a lot of el glutamide,
high concentrations of el glutamide, why?
Because el glutamide is a growth stimulator,
so it really helps increase replication of cells.
Well, boy, I shouldn't be drinking bone broth
as a cancer patient.
No, no cancer patient should be like doing a gap's diet.
A gap's diet is a diet where somebody
who's got really, really, really unhealthy gut,
and they're using bone broth and they're drinking
just very cooked soups.
They're making their own bone broth by boiling bones
at a simmer for several days to try to get as much glutamide
out of the bone as very healing to the gut.
Why? Because it causes rapid cell replication.
So should any cancer patient be doing a gap's diet?
No, I don't think any cancer patient should be doing bone broth.
Now, in that fashion, does that mean
that cancer patient can't have soup?
No, it's about balance.
You're going to get glutamide in other proteins as well,
but you're not making this concentrated glutamide soup.
And you're certainly not taking, you know,
high dose alglutamide in a supplement.
So remember, it's all about balance.
So you ought to do your research whether
how much glutamide is in the gelatin caps.
Maybe the veggie caps are better.
I don't know why I haven't done that research.
On his own test, he has high markers for high external,
as perjilous exposure or high internal yeast exposure.
Other than constipation, I don't think of him
as a candidate type person.
We have had mold testing at our home waiting for results
with everybody danger and giving him some grapefruit seed extract.
Probably not.
I would just start in low doses if you're concerned about that.
I don't think they'd be like the next part of this
says another practice that's just suggested killing yeast
can liberate heavy metals.
And that all has to do with killing yeast too quickly.
So you just want to go slow with anything
when you're dealing with any fungus or mold in the body
or a Lyme disease, same thing you don't want to kill quickly.
You might want to just be running some of these programs
on your right for sheet instead of,
especially with him,
when you're having trouble getting these supplements down,
if you have used your right then for these things.
Remember, underneath your program that I created for you,
there's literally 2,500 other programs for a lot of things.
Let that be your first goal to think
when you're looking at other diseases and such.
Constipation, I tried, they're ready to go.
That's a product by ortho molecular.
It didn't seem to help.
Started to give him magnesium citrate
because he had high oxalates at his oat test.
But it is taking three capsules to move the constipation.
The idea to reduce his capsules is band constipating.
So it's this copy twice.
So band really is not constipated.
What I would suggest though,
is if you want to reduce your capsules
and do the allol,
it's actually the product is ortho molecular product.
Super allol, 250.
And for somebody him,
you want to open up the capsule
and only give him a third of that at night before bed
and just give him a third of the capsule, the super allol 250.
If you are an adult and you have constipation,
start with the super allol 250.
Start with one capsule before bed.
This is the best thing for constipation.
You will get a little bit of cramping,
nothing like if you're taking a scena.
So super allol is a type of allol
that is really, really good for constipation issues.
So highly recommend that.
That will be much better than giving him the magnesium.
Remember, when you're sending cheek swabs to us,
send it to our new address.
Continue to remind you about that.
Write that down if you need.
When you're sending cheek swabs,
make sure you send it to our new address.
All right, some questions that you chatted in there.
I have a grounding blend essential oil.
Would it be beneficial to use this on my feet at night
when I'm cuddling with the right?
Would it work like a grounded cheek?
No, it won't work like a grounded cheek.
You won't lose frequencies to it at essential oil at all.
So yes, you could use that just by there's no negatives
about using that.
Now that it's getting warmer outside,
I'm spending my nights throwing my blankets on
and off repeatedly.
Right, that's all I'm sort of in here.
And I think that's interrupted my sleep a lot.
I'm used to cuddling with the bulb overnight,
but the heat it generates sometimes
could be contributed if I interupted sleep.
Is it better than to push the bulb away
or my body a few feet,
or maybe get better to better and I sleep?
Yeah, you have to have a balance
while that could start getting a good night's sleep.
It's not good.
I like a cool room to sleep in.
I just cannot sleep with what I feel like I'm hot.
So I know what you feel like.
So I open a window or go down the basement
if I have to to cool off.
So I do I that's why I like to she admitted so that
because I would rather be cold and trying to get warm
than warm and trying to get cold.
It's just just trying to be care easier
and care to do that.
So I hear you next question.
I gave blood for a Syrex 10 test last Thursday.
They said you would get the results than not be.
That is correct.
We do get the results.
Not you.
How long does it take?
It turns out busy.
They are usually it takes at least seven days total.
Sometimes seven to I've had a take two weeks
but usually it's within two weeks
that we get the results back.
Usually it's at least seven days,
no seven to 14 days.
We'll get those results and we'll let you know.
Let's schedule the time to go over it if you need.
The Syrex 10 test for those though,
that is a blood test for antibodies to over 300 different foods.
If you have a lot of inflammation in your body
you cannot call the tell for some reason.
Doing that is a very beneficial test.
It's a great test for people that have autoimmune disorders
that they're trying to call them down as well.
Because if you have antibody study food that you're eating
you may be causing a fire of inflammation in your body.
You don't have any symptoms of it.
So you could eat the food you won't.
Well, I don't have any trouble with gluten.
I could eat it all day long.
But actually you're causing this hyperinflammatory response
that's affecting your gut.
That's affecting your brain.
That's affecting the rest of your cells.
And that can be a hindrance to healing.
So doing a Syrex 10 test can be beneficial.
So that's what this person is talking about.
Any other questions?
Let's regard to fendizol.
The Joe Dippins protocol recently recommended taking it with a meal
because fat somehow helped.
I don't, Joe Dippins has added other things to his protocol.
Burberry, I think you just added.
He added, taking it with a meal.
Also, he now says ever take it every day
because it's not an issue.
So when we test people,
so we don't use the Joe Dippins protocol to understand.
So it is on our website with information
because it's Joe Dippins protocol.
And it's on our store.
We sell a Joe Dippins bundle.
Those are really to non-patients.
So when a person is a patient, we test them.
That's what you came here for us to get specific with you.
So we have a lot of people on fendizol.
This not taken the way he says it's taken the way it tests out on a person.
So we have people take two packets a day, seven days a week.
We have people take two packets a day, three days a week.
We have people take one packet a day,
five days a week.
It's all over the board.
It's depending on what comes up with the test.
So if the person asks this question,
I don't remember what your protocol is.
But if you're just choosing to do the Joe Dippins protocol,
which is everybody can choose to do what they want,
then you can play with those dosages and such.
Certainly taking, if you're following his protocol,
it's one packet of fendizol, which is equivalent to use for a 10-pound dog.
So there is no side effects, no danger in taking that.
So no harm in triply or quadruply your dosage really.
So you recommend three days on one pack, four days on.
If that's what I recommended for you, that's what came up and you're testing.
That is, I think, his standard protocol was three days on, four days off.
That's what's on our website.
That's what's on our store.
I understand what's on our website and what's on our store is for non-patients.
If that's what I recommended for you, that's what I recommended.
If you want to take it every day, that's your choice.
But if you do just let your liaison know so we can tweak it in your protocol,
what you are personally doing.
So remember, we are not our way or the highway type clinic.
We, our patients, the freedom to be, you know,
prayed about what they should be doing.
And certainly if they feel like they should be doing something else,
we want you to do that.
But I do ask that you just communicate that with us.
So we can at least put it in our notes as we know what you're doing.
So we can have it in our master list of your books.
Next question.
Since starting the hyperthermia, this is person started using the hyperthermia unit at home.
On my liver, I've noticed amber are concentrated looking urine intermittently.
I looked at a functional websites and found that correlation with liver function and this symptom.
My liver values are elevated but my, my bun is normal.
That's your blood, urea, nitrogen.
Lab, red, urine, screen, all normal.
I am definitely hydrated.
Okay, that would be question of the world.
Three liters of water and a cup of tea or so of the day.
My creatin was a little too low over hydrated and was told to me.
Is it typical to see this amber urine with hyperthermia or other liver supporting therapies?
I have not done the hyperthermia for a few days due to my chemo
and poor schedule and urine cleared up.
Just see a correlation with hyperthermia.
I have not heard that before.
My question is if you're just using it for 40 minutes a day over your liver or if you're using
multiple times over your liver, that would be a question.
I have not had anybody say this comment before so that's interesting.
I'll have to do some investigation of it.
Other questions.
I've had a long history of candida and perxine when treated.
For the first three weeks of using their rife, I felt good.
The last three weeks I felt I have been getting some ticks
more anxiety, pain in the chest, muscles, sternum, and other things.
Possibly perxine the candida.
So are you using the program that I created for you?
Are you ready to candida program?
Would this be a herx reaction for a candida or just normal for the rife program?
So if you're ready, the program that I created for you, you won't be perxine from candida.
So I would have to look, what was your program updated?
Contact your liaison and let me know.
I get to write your name down and see when I updated your program.
And if not, we might want to get a cheek swab update that if I have an update.
Okay, I didn't get my genetic test back.
I think it's still that the eight week period for that.
Okay, so you you started with us about eight weeks ago?
Well, I've only been using the rife for six weeks and I think that it took me another week.
I'm not exactly sure, but I know my genetic test wouldn't be back yet.
Okay, so don't need your genetic test.
I'm just wondering what rife program you're using.
I'm not using any candida programs at all, but I've been using all the programs you wrote for me
twice now and so I had 21 programs and I've gone through that two times and I've been using it.
Let's have you send it at other cheek swab and I want to look at your program and possibly do some
updating. You have a cheek swab in your binder. I made a note to look at
all these programs and see how we can tweak that.
I haven't used any candida programs, but I've been using all kind of other programs like
for attention deficit or for this pain I have in my chest, I've been using the pain like biobasic and
those ones should do that either.
Okay, are you you're not using any other kill programs like bacteria or a lot
of polymer, a mold?
Nope, none of those.
Because this is a mold for everybody, if you're you're running like I just said a couple of minutes
ago, run those other programs that are in your on your right, but if you're running kill programs,
so kill programs would be for a bacteria or a Lyme disease or a mold.
You can't hurt because this thing works and it can kill and it can't kill too fast.
So what a Herximer reaction is, is that you kill a bacteria too quickly or a fungus or a mold too
quickly, you end up with byproduct of the organisms spilled into the blood, you know, just waste,
spilled into the blood. And that's what a Herximer reaction is, so you could get really tired,
you could feel yucky, you could feel sick, you could just be a gamut of different symptoms.
And it's because you're killing too quickly. We see this a lot with Lyme patients,
very kind of with Lyme patients, you have to go really slow with kill programs.
So let me look at your program, let's get an update, send in the Sheik Swablin, we'll take a look at that.
Put in the membership link for a full time. Yeah, so if you're having,
if you have not been on the membership site, go to look at search your e-made email at info and cuttersfluteic.com
or just email me at info at cuttersfluteic.com. We'll say, please, I'm not able to get on the
membership site and I will send you with either link. So, and then make sure you search for that other
link in your, in your junk mail too. My mom has liver affected due to fluid accumulation in her
stomach area. How detox must be done? Remember, just got all your stuff for your mom don't. So,
just start there. You don't want to try to detox too quickly or anything like that. Just start using
the right, follow what is in your binder. You take the time to stop and open it up and read it
and use the right on her 24-7 if she's not fully ambulatory up and moving around and living her life.
So, use the right as much as possible on her. Anytime she's sitting down, you want to set up your
home that she could be right feed. Other than that, how you would help with detox pathways in the
liver, you have to go back and download on the website again, download. You just, that's the main
website. Think it's on the membership site too, but go to the main website, look for books, download
the detoxification book to help you understand that. But you, the person has got to be having a bowel
move into the least one a day. Make sure they're moving their bowel. And then you work on other things
stream from that. It's healthy with the liver, using a hot pack over the liver could be beneficial.
Pastoral oil pack over the liver could be beneficial. Coffee cannabis are one of the best things
to help with all of the pathways. So, other questions. Okay, well, we will end that now. This,
I will have time tonight to get this uploaded to YouTube. And you'll see it on the membership site.
If you're on this, I'll know why you're going to listen to it again. But, uh, and,
again, if you really want everybody to use that membership site. So, if you're having trouble to get
on it or anything, you need to do invite. All right. Thank you guys. I'll be praying for all of you.
And we will talk again next week.